HOCKEY.
THESE GAMES -- THEIR GAMES ARE .
>> THAT SHOT MISSED EVERYTHING.
CENTERING PASS, SHOT, SAVED BY
SCORE.
ALEXANDER KERFOOT IN ONE MOTION
HAD THATEN IN THE TOP SIX AND
HAS PLAYED WELL WITH MATTHEWS
SLOT, AND SCORE.
MATTHEWS GOT SIX SHOTS BY
HIMSELF AND IHAT ONE HOME.
YOU SEE HIM RIGHT IN THE CENTERG
AND NATHAN MacKINNON AND HEN THE
PLACE.
TOEWS JUMPS UP.
SPEZZA.
GIRARD ON THE BRIRCLE.
SIMMONS BACKHAND AND SCORTICALLO
GO DOWN TO THE
AUBE-KUBEL.OAL BY MacKINNON.
AND THIS ONE, WALKS BELOW.
WHAT A SAVE BY CAMPBELL ONF FORT
WENT OFF THE HEEL IN THE GUT.EL!
SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> THE AVS ARE PAD?
THAT WASN'T LEAFSANTANEN.
PUCK WILL COMEWS STRIPPED BY MI.
HERE COMES THE AVS ON
HIGH SLOT, RANTANEN.
POPS IT UP  THIS GUY HE
WON ME OVER WITH ED BY FRAZ.VS E